the problem that is obvious to you may
not necessarily be the solution
that exists in that problem when you
come up with a goal
that this is what you set out to do
it's amazing to see the world's best
resources
are attracted by the same purpose there
is not
a problem in the world that innovation
and entrepreneurship can't solve wanna
be happy
build a life not just a business hey
it's evan carl michael
and this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you
know there's something more inside
youtube you've got michael jordan level
genius at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and get the billionaire
mindset from the being jane that can
make
you rich enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one have an abundance mindset
what is the mindset of abundance so
mindset of abundance is really clear
you do not think that anything is not
possible or
anything is scarce the reason we find
things
scarce is because we think that what is
being done
is the only way of doing things right so
for example
50 years ago one of the rarest thing
was something called aluminium it is
plentiful
abundance on earth but it's never in a
pure form
it comes in the form of bauxite it was
extremely rare nobody could purify it
until the technology came along called
electrolysis
and then aluminium become abundant
we have the coke cans we throw away we
use them for everything
it was simply people found them to be
rare because they thought in a certain
way
so when you start to think that
everything that we value on earth
earth is nothing but a tiny dot in the
in the galaxy there is nothing that we
fight over
that we can't have abundance of whether
it is a land
whether it is water anything that you
think
whether it's called rare earth elements
they are called rare earth elements
they are not called rare moon elements
they are called rare mars elements
right anything that you find valuable
scares can be had in plentiful and you
talk about
education you talk about health care the
reason they are scarce is
because we continue to do the same
things in the same way
that has not changed and disrupted in
the last 50 or 100 years
rule number two make a commitment i went
on a national tv
and i said i am going to start a company
whose sole purpose is going to be
to make illness optional
and once you make a public commitment
amazing things happen
that becomes you and you're not gonna go
back because you just told the world
what you're going to do
and when you have that audacious
moonshot
the universe comes together the people
around the world will come together to
help you
because that's the cause worth solving
that is the problem worth solving
and a lot of successful people want to
do something for their legacy
they are successful they want to be
significant and here is amazing thing
happened
when i say that i got a call from the
head of the ibm watson research
he's i have been working on the
artificial intelligence for 25 years
if you can tell me what's happening
inside the human body
i can analyze it and give you everything
that people need to do
not to be sick the second call i got was
a woman named dr
helen messier she said i'm a phd in
microbiology
and md i'm functional medicine i'm
working for the
craig venter on human longevity to
increase the life of people
and she said what's the point living
longer if people are going to be sick
anyway
i'm going to quit my job and i'm going
to come and help you make
illness optional right
now i still don't know what to do
because i still don't understand
any of this stuff an amazing thing is
going on now
now i am i i'm going to los alamos
national lab
and many many of you know at los alamos
you know what is famous for los angeles
national lab is
atomic bomb that's it's called manhattan
project wasn't done in manhattan it was
done at los alamos
these people know thing or two about
national security
i got a i was there talking about
completely different thing
and one guy walked up to me said i heard
you on tv
you want to make illness optional and i
said yes
he said you know we are working on a
biodefense technology
that because we developed it for a
simple reason we were worried some bad
actors were going to get hold of
something biological how would we know
what is making people sick so we develop
the technology that can look deep inside
your body
every single organism what it is how
active it is and what it's doing and we
can tell you exactly what is going on
inside the human body
that was the missing piece and he said
i'm going to quit my job and you can
license this technology and you can go
build that
guess what happened we got the exclusive
license to this technology worldwide
and i'm going to tell you a story about
how that happened and because this
they spent billions of dollars
developing this and they gave me the
exclusive license
because so i went there and i talked to
the tech transfer office and i say i
really like this technology
and the guy at that point would say that
look
we are not here to make money even if
you're wildly successful my salary is
going to be exactly the same
it makes no difference to us whether
you're successful or you fail
but if you fail and our name goes with
that
i would lose my job so i have all the
incentive in the world to tell you no
and there is not one thing that can make
me say yes
right got back to the exactly the same
thing with the moon express right
this time i started a different approach
i went and i talked to
all the scientists at the evening i told
them that you guys
all been so kind to me about explaining
what you do here
i'm going to give you a world of advice
and he said what's that
so i'm now sitting here i said you know
believe it or not one day you're all
going to get old and you're all going to
someday if you're lucky you're going to
have grandkids
and your grandkids are going to ask you
grandpa you were working at this lab
what were you doing and wasn't there
time you could have done something that
could have changed the way people live
their lives
and if you're honest with yourself you
have to say you know there was a brown
guy who came here
and he said he could fix he could change
the way people are going to live their
lives he wanted to make illness optional
but i was so afraid of losing my job i
told him no
i said that's the guilt you have to live
the rest of your life
every day when you're looking in the
mirror you have to always answer to
yourself
when i said no their problem could have
been solved because someone was
dedicating their life to solving that
problem
and now you have to think back and
saying do you still want to say no
or could the answer be yes guess what
happened
the answer was yes he said if you are
willing to dedicate your life
right
so what i'm here to tell you is that i
took this moonshot and this is my
seventh company and as you know
any measure of success you can look at
i have been wildly successful why at my
age i would decide that i'm going to
work 18 hours a day
seven days a week i could be sitting on
any island and enjoying my life
i do this because i have that still have
the debt of the society on my head
and before i die i'm gonna pay that debt
back and i'm going to solve this problem
rule number three trust your gut as a
young entrepreneur i learned
several valuable lesson but i think the
most valuable lesson i learned
was trusting your own gut instinct it's
not about the spreadsheets
it's not about the numbers it is about
what you feel in your heart just
remember there are so
many variables in the real life a
spreadsheet can never capture them
the brain only works on the logic of
zeros and one
and it doesn't know how to deal with a
lot of the gray areas
your gut your heart is a chemical
computer it computes
things on a fuzzy fuzzy magic fuzzy
logic that means a lot of the times
you'll start to feel that something
doesn't feel right
even though the numbers do add up rule
number four think
like an entrepreneur in today's world
the philanthropy is considered where you
give the money to someone
and if you don't give the money you are
a bad person somehow you don't care
enough
and to me philanthropy should never be
about giving money
philanthropy should be about solving a
problem so
this lady came to me uh saying you know
we have done
such a good job in our current homeless
shelter we really
outgrown it and now we need to expand it
and we have this
capital need and we want you to donate
to it
and i said instead of asking for a
donation why don't you start to think
about like a business
and i am a venture capitalist and if you
came to me
saying that give me this money that is
going to go out and do something
with it the only two choices you're
giving me
either you're going to fail in doing
what you're doing in that case the money
is wasted
and if you do succeed you're going to
come back and ask me for more money
so how is that going to be a sustainable
business model
and she said what do you really mean i
say ask yourself a question just like
any other business
what is your product and who is your
customer
she looked at me all she wanted to do is
write a check
and not be interviewed and she said it's
really simple
all i'm selling is the homeless shelter
the place in the homeless shelter and my
customers are my woman
who come there and i say young lady you
have a broken business model
and she said why i see your customers
don't pay you i said they're not your
customers they're your users
and she said how would you how else
would you think about it
and i said what if just like a facebook
the social networking is not their
product the people who use social
networking
is the product you and i are the product
and the customer
is the advertisers in the same way in a
women's shelter
the women are the product and local
businesses
are your customers and the more products
you have
the more you can cater to the local
businesses so why don't you go to local
businesses
and say i have this amazing product the
women who are so driven
that they would go out and do the things
you want them to do you will have a
loyal
employee you will teach them the skills
and you will have these people working
you will be doing good for the society
and you will have a loyal employee and
if you do that the more
people you have in your shelter the
higher the revenue you're going to have
and you'll be continuing to expand that
and just that thought process
she implemented and suddenly now they're
growing everywhere
right she actually did it she actually
did it whoa i did
not think that was going to be the
punchline yeah so my point is this is
how
entrepreneurs really need to be thinking
about and i can give you several
examples of that
the problem that is obvious to you may
not necessarily be the solution
that exists in that problem for example
is
everybody knows the lack of fresh water
is a problem
a lot of people go out and try to clean
the water because thinking
the fresh water is really the scarce
resources
until you start to dig into it what
where is the fresh water being used
and suddenly you realize the majority of
the fresh water is used in the
agriculture
all you have to do is solve the
agriculture problem and whether you use
the aeroponic or
aquaponic or other mechanism or even
lightly salted water
that could solve the agriculture problem
suddenly you have abundance of fresh
water
and then you feel really good about
yourself also if you want to have more
self-confidence and self-belief
the sign says it can take up to 254
days of consecutive action for the habit
to stick that's what i want for you so
i've designed a custom
free program we're going to send you an
unlisted video for the next 254 days
to shift your confidence and belief
forward
the link to join is in the description
below we have a lot of heroes
but china movies heroes always dead the
american
movie hero never die if
all the heroes die who want to be the
hero you have a great product lots of
people will buy it
and then the company will be successful
most of the best
entrepreneurial ideas come out of
frustration rule number five
be persistent but flexible another
valuable lesson i learned
was being persistent while being
flexible
lot of entrepreneurs spend way too much
time
writing a business plan rather than
really doing things
as you are continuing to execute you
will find
new things you will learn new valuables
the trick
is to have your business plan which only
provides you the guidelines
but not the road map because as you are
going out and doing things in real world
you will find things will never ever
turn out to be
the way you expected them when you
started a business so it's not don't try
to stick to your business plan or spend
too much time writing a business plan
but learn as you're executing on a
business plan
and you will find yourself to be
successful rule number six pursue
crazy ideas seven years ago when i
started saying we are going to go to the
moon
and we are going to mine for the
resources and people say that's a
freaking crazy idea
and when someone tells you it's a crazy
idea that means you're on the right path
because dreams so big that people think
you're absolutely crazy and when you
tell them what you're going to do and if
they don't think it's crazy idea you're
not thinking big enough
so think big and when the reason is when
someone tells you it is impossible
it becomes impossible for them not for
you
and the more people who tell you it's
impossible that means more people have
taken themselves
out of the solution and now the field is
yours to on yours only
right and that's just a different way of
looking at it so when i look at
as an entrepreneur i don't focus on what
the world
is i focus on what the world can be
so don't look at the glass being half
empty or half full
you focus on saying is this glass worth
filling
do i want to fill this glass or not
because if i do does it really matter is
half empty or half full
and if i don't that the do i really care
is half empty or half full right
and that to me is really starting to
think about
every time you see something and you say
what is possible
what if and imagine are the two amazing
words in the english dictionary
so when i say lewis imagine what happens
to you
all your preconceptions go away and
you're willing to open to
anything that i'm willing to say for at
least the next 30 seconds
of imagining and then you may come back
and say oh that will never work
but at least you're open for that time
rule number seven
have a big goal the only reason we don't
do something the resistance that warren
talks about is
because we are not we don't have a
purpose in life the
purpose is too small when you come up
with a big purpose
all your resistance goes away because
it's not about you anymore
it's about that big goal you have and
once you set your eyes on that big goal
then every single hurdle in your way it
starts to look like a tiny speed bump
and here's the best part the people
around you in the world
will come together to make your dream
come true
and that is what i found when you come
up with a goal
that this is what you set out to do
it's amazing to see the world's best
resources are attracted by the same
purpose
and they will quit what they are doing
to come join you
in making that happen the resources the
money
from around the world will come to you
to make that dream happen because if
it's your dream that can help a billion
people
there are at least enough people out
there who want to help those billion
people
and that's how you change the world rule
number eight solve
big problems there is not a problem
in the world that innovation and
entrepreneurship
can't solve so you look at me and saying
what do you know about entrepreneurship
what is an entrepreneur
who is an entrepreneur so i say there
are three types of people in the world
people who actually can see the problem
and let's call them human beings
right and there's some of us who can
even find a solution to that problem
and we're going to call them visionaries
or even coach or even consultants
and there are few people in this room
who can actually go out and do something
about it and we're going to call them
entrepreneurs
entrepreneurs are the ones who are the
problem solvers who just don't see the
problem
who just don't come up with a solution
who go out and do something about it
and those are the entrepreneurs we
celebrate
so you look back and saying if
innovation and entrepreneurship can
solve all the problem
why every time we walk we see a problem
and we ask the same question
why is it someone do something about it
why can't someone do something about
this
here is a big problem why can't someone
do something about it the question you
should be asking is
what is it that i can do about it what
can i do about it to solve this problem
that's an entrepreneurial mindset and
that's how you solve a problem
there's not a problem how big a problem
it is i will tell you
it's no easier to build a hundred
million dollar company
to then build to build a billion dollar
company in fact i'll argue
it's so much easier to build a billion
dollar company than to build a hundred
million dollar company you have to think
so small
you can't think big when you're trying
to build a hundred million dollar
company
you got to be saying why can't we go to
the moon
what stops us from going to the moon
what stops us from solving big problems
and never be afraid to say and my
company is profitable and i make money
if you want to make a billion dollar how
do you make a billion dollar
you go out and solve a 10 billion dollar
problem and it so
happens that those 10 billion dollar
problems happen to be large
social problems education health care
clean water energy and imagine that
if one of you out there solves a clean
water problem for
around the world for billions of people
and if you happen to make a billion
dollar
somebody's gonna say look at that greedy
entrepreneur
my hat's off to you
[Laughter]
so my purpose in life is really simple
go out
and think about the large problems and
see
how innovation can solve it rule number
nine focus on the future of technology
how much did it cost for us to go to the
moon before so the cost in 1960 was 25
billion dollars oh my god and in today's
dollars there will be a hundred billion
dollars
right and so that would have been price
prohibitive and from a business
perspective would not have made sense
right
it costs the 10 million dollars it
starts to make sense right
so bringing this stuff back and
obviously you know there is platinum
grade material there is helium-3 there
you know helium-3 is an amazingly
clean energy fuel resource that means
you can use a
small quantity of helium 3 in a fusion
reactor
and you can power this planet for
generations
yeah yeah and here's the thing people
say fusion reactor did you say fusion
don't you know that we don't have a
fusion reactor right now and i said i do
but you i don't have helium-3 either
right but the point is in the next 10
years when we are able to scale and
start to bring
helium-3 the technology will be there
for fusion
and when these guys have a fusion
reactor they're going to be looking
around and say does anybody have
helium-3
and that's when you said yep got
something right so my point is as an
entrepreneur
your job is not to be where the puck is
you focus on where the puck is going to
be of course right and so you start to
look at where the technology is headed
and you start to plan for that annual
number 10 the last one before some very
special bonus clips
is give 100
business is like a war you have to be
completely
prepared and unless you have mind body
and soul really all
are ready for it you just can't fight
that battle
i do work very very long hours and i
realize there is really no substitute i
mean it doesn't matter how smart you are
and there is just no substitute for hard
work
[Music]
if you want to succeed in life you have
to be absolutely at your best
and the only way to be absolutely the
best is to give it
100 of yourself
this is my commuter car so i drive it
every day to work most people buy car
and keep in the garage i drive them
every day
a lot of people assume that
entrepreneurs
take chances is that true not true at
all in fact entrepreneurs
actually hate risk only play the game
that you can win
making money is a byproduct of doing
things that you really
enjoy doing it is never a goal in itself
and it's like having sex and orgasm you
have to enjoy the process and not focus
on the end goal people actually who
focus on end goal like getting an orgasm
never get one
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day i want to know what was your
single biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week the science says that when you just
watch a video
you get motivated to get inspired you
have a 35 chance
of following through on your goals 35
that's not enough that's not enough just
to get motivated
believe nation we're here you're here
today matters you're an action
taker when you commit to a plan of
action of
when and how you're going to follow
through when you write it down you have
a 91
chance of following through and when you
commit publicly to somebody else it
jumps to 95
chance from 30 something percent to 95
chance of you following through believe
nation we need to make this happen
so question of the day your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action specific for the
next week
put it down in the comments below and
i'm going to show on screen
sometime next week to celebrate you
think differently it's not about
thinking outside the box it's about
thinking in a different box
if you become an expert in your field
you become
absolutely useless in your field because
the day you become an expert
you become incrementalist you think
about incremental evolution
so if you want to disrupt something go
out in a completely different industry
that you know nothing about
because then you're thinking abstract so
never be afraid to talk to
about your problem to someone who knows
nothing about your industry because they
will come up with a ways that you have
never thought before
[Music]
if you want to see the top 10 rules i
made on the bean jane check it out right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there when would we be able to tell your
honey
that i want to take you to the moon 10
years 10 years
entrepreneurs never fail their ideas may
or may not work
and you know what